this week in Bitcoin there's three
stories that I think are worth paying
attention to the first is the continued
Fallout from FTX as the mainstream media
continues to treat Sam bakeman freed and
the FTX situation with kid gloves
bitcoiners appear to be undeterred we
have seen over a hundred thousand
Bitcoin taken off major exchanges this
is people taking self-custody of their
coins not your keys not your coins
appears to be a mantra that is now being
put into effect on top of that we see
Bitcoin wallet addresses on chain with
0.01 Bitcoin hitting all-time high after
all-time high these are individuals
stacking SATs regardless of what
organizations institutions and nation
states are doing but also we do see
nation states specifically El Salvador
continuing to embrace Bitcoin president
bukeli has stated that El Salvador is
going to buy one Bitcoin per day in
perpetuity moving forward the nation
states are not the only people who are
actually making moves in this
environment we we also saw JP Morgan
come out and launch a brand new crypto
wallet anytime that you see nation
states and large financial institutions
like JP Morgan embracing a technology
especially when it is down 75 plus
percent from its all-time high that
tells you that the action in the
industry is diverging from the price of
the assets there will be continued
Fallout from FTX in the weeks to come
but I still believe the main story in
Bitcoin is the macro environment what is
the Federal Reserve going to do will
they pivot will they return to a loose
monetary policy or will they remain
committed to tightening Financial
conditions raising interest rates and
selling assets in the market I don't
know what they're going to do in the
short term but over a long period of
time it is pretty obvious that they will
have to return to that loose monetary
policy and if you have a loose monetary
environment a finite asset like Bitcoin
should continue to do well over long
periods of time understand that there is
risk to bitcoin coin but remember that
Timeless investing principles appear to
serve investors well dollar costs
averaging into a great asset that you
hold for a long period of time is
something that everyone from Warren
Buffett to the most hardcore bitcoiners
Embrace when it comes to investment
strategy ultimately Bitcoin is showing
to be a resilient technology there's all
kinds of chaos and uncertainty in the
market but Bitcoin just doesn't care it
is producing block after block after
block of transactions and it appears
that nothing will shake the confidence
of the everyday individual holders